[SOUND] As you've seen,
Android Auto provides
an integration between your phone and
your car.
This allows you to make your phone
perform tasks without having to touch
the phone display.
This is great because the user
is driving, meaning they need
minimal distractions and they need
to keep their eyes on the road.
One of the key features of
Android Auto is messaging support.
Let's have a quick look
at what this might like.
[SOUND]
>> Here's the message.
Are you coming back to the studio for
filming?
[SOUND]
>> Reply.
>> What's the message?
[SOUND]
>> Yes, in five minutes.
>> Got it.
Here's your message.
Yes, in five minutes.
Do you want to send it?
[SOUND] Yes.
[SOUND]
>> Sending message.
>> As you can see,
this is a very simple workflow.
In this lesson,
I'm going to show you the following.
How to get an existing sample for
notifications, how it works, and
then how to get it running.
Then, I'm going to show you
how to add extensions for
Android Auto Messaging, and then how
to test that messaging functionality
on the Android Auto Simulator.
Let's head back to the studio and
get started.